[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM KOCH: Hi.
My name's Adam Koch from the
Android Developer Relations
team at Google.
Today, I wanted to talk
to you about the new SMS
APIs in Android 4.4 KitKat.
So let's jump right in.
Starting with
Android 4.4 KitKat,
there's the new concept of
a default SMS application.
Only the default SMS
application can write directly
to the system ContentProvider.
Other apps that try and
write will fail silently.
Of course, any app can
still read from the system
ContentProvider as long as they
have the correct permission.
So you might be
thinking, why do we
need this new concept
of a default SMS app?
In previous versions
of Android, you
could already assign some of the
SMS intents to any application.
But the difference is, that
app had no unique privileges
over any other
app on the system.
With the new default
SMS app selection,
that app will now have
additional privileges
and be guaranteed to get
every single message.
Another app cannot abort
the delivery of the SMS
or interrupt that flow.
This helps to
increase reliability.
Additionally, no other app
can delete or alter messages
out from underneath
the default app, which
helps to decrease complexity
within the default SMS app.
This, combined with
the fact that some
of the previously private APIs
in earlier versions of Android
are now public, means
that third-party SMS apps
are supported first-class
citizens of the Android system.
So let's talk about
implementation.
To be eligible as
the default SMS app,
you must support some
specific capabilities.
In your AndroidManifest,
you have
to define two
receivers to handle
the receiving of
SMSes and MMSes.
You can see here
that the actions are
SMS_DELIVER and
WAP_PUSH_DELIVER You'll also
note that these
receivers require
an additional permission
on the actual receiver.
Additionally, you have to
define an activity, a UI that
can handle creation
of new SMSes.
So here we've got a
ComposeSmsActivity.
This might be triggered, say,
from the system people app
when you go and create a new
SMS to a particular contact.
And lastly, you
also need a service
that can also respond to
creating and sending new SMSes.
This is used by the system
when a phone call comes in.
And if you can't take
it, you can quickly
swipe up to send an
SMS in the background
to the person saying the
reason why you can't actually
take that call.
Once you've defined
all of these things,
you'll be eligible to show up
in a new system dialogue that
lets you choose the
default SMS app.
Additionally, you can
also display a dialogue
that lets the user switch to
your application as the default
SMS app.
And I'll show you how to do
that shortly, after this.
One thing worth noting
is that you still
need to declare the same
application-wide permissions
that you always did to
access SMS functionality,
things like WRITE_SMS,
READ-SMS, SEND_SMS, RECEIVE_SMS,
and RECEIVE_MMS.
In some of the
previous slides, you
will have seen that two
receivers we defined
have two new KitKat delivery
actions, SMS_DELIVER_ACTION
and WAP_PUSH_DELIVER_ACTION.
These only get delivered to
the default SMS application.
But in previous
versions of Android,
there was actually
a private API that
allowed you to also
receive these SMSes.
These actions were
SMS_RECEIVED_ACTION
and WAP_PUSH_RECEIVED_ACTION.
And these still exist in KitKat
and are actually now public.
And applications can
still listen to them
as they did before.
To distinguish the
difference between these two,
think of SMS_RECEIVED_ACTION as
the system has received an SMS.
Whereas the
SMS_DELIVER_ACTION says
the system is delivering
your app and SMS
because you are the
default SMS app.
So let's talk about some
message receiver best practices.
For apps that are not looking
to become the default,
they should just carry
on as normal using
the "message received" actions.
These are the ones
that, as I mentioned,
were private before KitKat,
but are now public in KitKat.
For apps that do want
to become the default,
they should probably
be listening
to both the "message received"
and then new SMS delivered
ones.
So that means that when
they're running on KitKat,
they should really
disabled the one
that's not being used, the
"message received" actions.
To do that, they should use the
PackageManager.setComponentEnabledSetting
method.
That way, they
can disable these,
and they won't be using
unnecessary resources
and be triggered as
new SMSes come in.
Another approach
to handling them
is to use Boolean resource
files to automatically enable
and disable the receivers
based on platform version.
Really, the difference
between these two
is that
setComponentEnabledSetting
is a little more flexible.
You can choose within code
when you want to change it.
Whereas the Boolean resource
is simpler, but less flexible.
So let's quickly look at how
you would implement the Boolean
method.
Here, you see we've
created two Boolean XML
files in our
resource directories,
one under the default res/values
directory, with two values,
hasKitKat and preKitKat.
We've additionally
created another one
in values-v19, which means any
devices running on Android 4.4
KitKat or above
will automatically
load this resource file instead.
And you can see we've
set hasKitKat to true
and preKitKat to false.
Then, in our
AndroidManifest file,
in our receiver declarations,
we assign this Boolean
to the Android-enabled
attribute.
This has the effect that on
certain versions of Android,
one will be enabled
and the other disabled,
and the reverse on
the newer platforms.
If you haven't seen
this technique before,
follow the link here on
the right or the QR code
to get more information.
Another new API in
KitKat is the ability
to check which is the default
SMS application, using
the
Telephony.Sms.getDefaultSmsPackage
method.
Here you can see,
we're checking to see
if we're running
on KitKat or above,
and then we're going
to use that method
to work out if we're currently
the default SMS application.
You can then call
this in your onResume
of your key activities, hide
and show certain layouts as
appropriate, and also
enable and disable
certain functionality
as appropriate.
For example, you may not
want to allow sending SMSes
if you're not currently the
default SMS application.
You can also open
a system dialogue
to ask the user if they would
like to switch the default SMS
application to be yours.
To do this, you use a new intent
action, ACTION_CHANGE_DEFAULT,
along with an extra
EXTRA_PACKAGE_NAME
to pass your package name
to another activity, which
opens a system dialogue that
looks something like this,
that I showed you before.
As soon as the user clicks
Yes, your application
will now be the default.
Your previous activity will
get a call to unresume,
and it can adjust its layouts
and functionality as needed.
Lastly, some additional notes.
Messages can still be sent
by any application using
the existing SmsManager
APIs, assuming, of course,
they hold the send
SMS permission.
However, for apps other
than the selected default,
the system writes all
outgoing SMS messages
to the system provider
automatically.
It won't, however,
write outgoing MMS.
This is particularly important
for auxiliary SMS apps that
may work alongside another
app which is the default.
One thing worth noting,
though, these auxiliary apps
will no longer be able to
write to the system content
provider themselves.
So they won't be
able to do things
like deleting messages
or marking messages
as read or unread.
On the flip side, the
default SMS application
is responsible for writing its
outgoing messages to the system
provider.
Lastly, SMS backup apps will
need to temporarily become
the default when
restoring messages
so that they can write correctly
to the system content provider.
For additional reference to
the new SMS APIs in KitKat,
see the Android
Developer blog, where
we have additional
information posted up.
You can follow this
link or this QR code
on the right side of the screen.
We'll actually be posting some
sample code up and linking
to it in the description
of this video
and also on the blog post.
Thanks for tuning
in to this DevByte.